[Music]
drug testing is like a big business and
one of the key people in the big
business of drug testing is a guy who
once testified in favor of one of the
most abusive rehabs in American history
and he now is like a bigwig in the drug
testing field and this guy this program
literally tortured people they would
like hold kids down on the floor til
they wet or soiled themselves um as
punishment they would punch them they
would you know sleep deprived them for
like 48 or 72 hours they would make them
go through a spanking machine I mean it
was all kinds of really stupid horrible
traumatic and they would constantly
emotionally attack these kids in order
to break them 50,000 American kids went
through this program which was known as
Street incorporated and the people who
enabled it the people who said this was
the best program are still out there
trying to sell monitoring for people who
use drugs and I find that offensive I
just think that if you have done
something that is so harmful to people
that left many families broken and left
you know at least thousands of people
with PTSD on that you probably should
not be having anything to do with
anybody who uses drugs addiction is a
very human problem and this is often why
people propose and some people benefit
from a spiritual solution to it that's
not to say we should treat medicine and
medical conditions with spirituality but
the reality is that addiction and
depression and a lot of other mental
illnesses do often involve struggling
with existential questions and so it is
not going to be the case that you can
just put a brain implant in and
addiction will go away without a big
chunk of yourself going away so um you
know the Chinese are horribly
experimenting with this horrific brain
surgery where they oblate ie burn out
the nucleus accumbens which is basically
the brain region that provides pleasure
and motivation and they think that this
is actually going to
cure addiction of course what happens is
you get people who are just anhedonic
and who relapse because you know now
they have even less so you know this
idea that like we could use a drug that
will block the effects of the drug of
choice is generally misguided because
the problem isn't the drug of choice the
problem is why you need that drug and
why those drugs appeal to you and why
you are trying to get out why you were
trying to escape and what you need in
your life in order to feel comfortable
and safe and productive so I don't think
that there will be future weird cures
like that but what I do think is
interesting about the future of drugs is
that we can make better drugs part of
the reason that prohibition is
collapsing at the moment is because of
what are called new psychoactive
substances or legal hides and basically
you can make a new recreational drug by
sort of tweaking molecules of the other
ones and it will be technically legal
because it hasn't been made illegal and
what this reveals is that our system for
making drugs illegal is completely
irrational and based on you know 19th
century prejudices has nothing to do
with science and if we apply science to
this problem and look at well people are
always going to want to alter their
consciousness in some ways how do we
reduce the harm associated with this how
do we create drugs or medications that
will allow people to feel safe and
comfortable in the world but not be so
distracting or problematic that they
will not be able to feel you know
connect with other people they won't be
so you know out of it
so I think the future of drugs is better
drugs I don't think the future of drugs
will be or you know you could virtual
reality these kinds of things could all
be very interesting but I think that so
long as people ask the question why am I
here and so long
as people need each other to love and
connect we are going to have people who
want to find ways to make that work
better
[Music]
you